so Eddie Brock is fighting Doctor Doom
and the ending of this story is amazing
okay so what this does picking off the
last video that we did is this starts
off with Eddie Brock fighting Bedlam now
we will explain Bedlam and that kind of
stuff and once we get towards the end of
the video the long and short of this is
that Bedlam is what Eddie Brock will
become at some future point in time but
imagine a version of Eddie Brock as
Venom that's nothing but like rage and
anger right like a Hulk venom if you
want to call it that that's what Bedlam
basically becomes and so Eddie
confronting Bedlam here is actually for
the purpose of taking him over absorbing
him into himself and Eddie Brock can do
that because remember he has this
massive power boost Eddie Brock is a
king in Black which basically means that
he can tap into anyone who is a symbiote
who is basically a version of Venom
Carnage toxin all those different guys
or anyone who has ever been possessed by
a Venom symbiote so say for example that
Franklin Richards from the Fantastic
Four gets his crazy reality warping
Powers again and he ends up becoming a
version of Venom right a symbiote
attaches itself to him Eddie Brock can
tap into that power now he can literally
access reality warping abilities that's
what Marvel's pushing towards when it
comes to his character it's a huge and
massive boost to what this guy is
potentially capable of now the fight
between himself and Bedlam is pretty
straightforward so literally it's Bedlam
just for the most part thrashing Eddie
Brock but at the end of the day it
doesn't make any difference because
Eddie has total control over his body
meaning any injury he sustains he can
recover from and that's exactly what
happens Bedlam like swallows him chews
him up turns him in just kind of like a
fleshy pulp and then spits him out under
any normal circumstance it would be the
end of whoever this happened to be but
for Eddie Brock he reconstitutes himself
all of his organs are reconstituted he
literally healed and he's right back
into the battle again so you could argue
Eddie Brock is nigh indestructible now
right like it's impossible to kill this
guy and so in response to that what he
does is fire nerve endings out of his
hand into the mind of bedlam it's
excruciating but it allows him to enter
into bedlam's own head and when he does
he kind of starts to chastise him a
little bit but he really talks about the
nature of who they are and what they're
capable of now this is when we kind of
get into the conversation about Bedlam
and Meridius and all these different
guys so as a bit of a refresher for
those of you guys who are already
familiar with this and as an explanation
for those of you guys who are not for
years and years and years of Marvel
Comics Venom was just like a bad guy who
fought Spider-Man sometimes what
Marvel's been doing recently is they
basically constructed a kind of time
Loop which is to say in every Universe
there is a king in Black which is a
person this tasked for the purpose of
manipulating time as they need to in any
one particular Universe in order to
ensure that the Universe follows its
quote unquote natural course what that
natural course is is basically whatever
the writer wants it to be or whatever
Marvel wants it to be and then you just
kind of go forward from there but where
the celestials had created the beyonders
to essentially manipulate the Multiverse
from the outside effectively ensuring
that if the celestials ever went to war
again that the beyonders would be able
to destroy the celestials the kings in
Black manipulate the universe from
within and so they're basically
opposites but they're also incredibly
powerful what we ended up learning here
is that the first king in black or
really the most recent King in Black was
null the Symbiote God but instead of
falling in line with the task assigned
to him by the celestials he rebelled he
killed one of them created the all-black
necro sword went to war against them
created the Symbiotes and then was
ultimately defeated following the defeat
of null at the hands of Eddie Brock
Eddie Brock became the new King in Black
what's so interesting thing about this
is that it was supposed to be Spider-Man
Peter Parker because he's the one that
got the symbiote suit in secret Wars
from 1984 such as it was he cast the
suit off it went to Eddie and Eddie
became the king in Black instead right
something that we're just recently
learning in Marvel but the kicker about
all this is that Eddie Brock becomes
Venom at some point in the future he
will become Finnegan then he'll become
Bedlam and he'll go through all these
different iterations of himself
ultimately becoming Meridius this just
Nai omnipotent symbiote type guy who
seemingly Way Beyond The Power of null
and then eventually he'll become the
eventuality basically a god-like being
in terms of the power he possesses but
the big goal that's going on here is
that he doesn't want to become Meridius
so what he's doing is literally trying
to find a way to overcome the power of
Meridius while at the same time
accessing a time machine in order to
prevent his Ascension to Meridius by
both saving his son and then stopping
Meridius deadness tracks right we don't
know exactly how that's going to play
out but the fact remains right in this
kind of mindscape conflict between
himself and what's basically Bedlam this
is why you have Eddie with a beard who's
the modern day version of Eddie Bedlam
looks like Eddie Brock from the 1990s
the old school muscle-bound Eddie Brock
who was just a gigantic dick but at the
end of the day despite how Bedlam looks
he is still just a symbiote right like a
black Symbiote that basically looks red
because of its physical form Eddie Brock
gets the upper hand on Bedlam and when
he does he absorbs the Symbiote into
himself and this basically allows him to
take on a new form which has like four
arms now the thing about this is that
Eddie is going to be his normal self
going forward into the future of this
but Bedlam will just kind of manifest
occasionally depending on the
circumstances when he fights Doom that's
when it gets amazing and the way this
happened and as it initially picks up
with Eddie Brock arriving in latviria
now one of the things to understand when
you travel to the country of Liberia you
pay your money and take your chances
right that's just the way that it goes
if you start breaking laws you're going
to end up in a prison cell down in the
basement of Doom's castle and you're
just going to stay there for the rest of
your life and no amount of bargaining by
any government anywhere is going to see
you set free in any capacity right so
you're literally just going to destroy
your life when Eddie Brock gets here
he's met by what isn't affect the TSA
Liberia's version of the TSA but
basically doombots right and the thing
about this those of you guys who aren't
really familiar with that Dr Doom
doesn't show up all that often it has
this actual self when he goes out into
the world instead he sends in robots
that are designed to look and act like
him and depending on the complexity of
the doombot sometimes the Doom bot
itself will not know that it's not
Doctor Doom it'll actually believe it's
doomed right it makes for a very very
convincing circumstance in this instance
these guys are more just kind of uh
following instructions than anything
else so sort of the typical robot that
you would expect to see and when Eddie
Brock is told like open your bag so we
can search it he literally manifests
Bedlam and Bedlam just like choose this
guy up and then destroys him and that's
it following that a fight breaks out
between all of them now one of the
things to know and this is a testament
to this new level of durability and
power that Eddie Brock has he's able to
take on three different Doom bots now
none of these guys are on the same level
of power as Dr Doom himself but they are
immensely powerful incredibly powerful
so much so that Eddie Rock being able to
even just survive this experience let
alone turn around and Destroy them all
is kind of mind-boggling now this is an
instance when he basically releases
Bedlam and allows bedelum to basically
bond to Eddie himself and then just
start tearing everything up and so at
that point you switch over to doomstadt
writes you know a few hours later or
what have you and you've got one of the
doombots meeting with Dr Doom and this
is how this whole situation works it's
really really fascinating right Doom
looks at this Doom bot and starts
talking to it and says okay so like
Eddie Brock escaped our forces you have
obviously failed me but the response of
the Doom bot because it is an aspect of
Doom is like but Doom can't fail and the
response of Doom is but like you did
though right so here's the question
surely with someone like Eddie Brock
showing up on the scene and attacking
all of you guys surely you didn't just
bring in every single Doom bot of course
you had to have had one in reserve that
would serve the purpose of just tracking
his whereabouts and following him and
the response of this doombot is I did
not right it made a mistake it failed it
destroys itself right that's the price
that it pays for failing Doctor Doom
right then you get a knock on the door
Doctor Doom says enter and Eddie Brock
just comes smashing through the door for
no other reason than the fact that when
it comes to Doctor Doom you kind of have
to make an impression when you show up
to him right it's one of those things
where like you can't just show up to Dr
Doom with flowers in your hand and say
hey I've come here to take you on a date
you gotta like fly in with a helicopter
right and like come out in like an
amazing suit or something along those
lines it's got to be grandiose it's got
to be big because Dr Doom only really
respects people that he sees as being
equal to himself with Eddie Brock
becoming a king in Black Dr Doom is one
of the very few people out there in the
Marvel Universe did actually understands
what this means and understands the
significance of the power that Eddie has
because despite how it may seem Eddie
Brock is just as powerful as null the
Symbiote God he's not using his powers
in the same capacity but he's every bit
as powerful and capable as this guy and
of course because he's a king in Black
Dr Doom respects the position that he
has and so it's a really interesting
thing here because what ends up
happening is Eddie Brock kind of
explains the situation and basically
saying I can time travel but it's my
mind that goes and I can't change stuff
with that only be the cause of it and
that's the issue he's had up to this
point right that was the whole thing
with Dylan that's why he's doing
everything that he's doing his son Dylan
was basically met by Meridius
masquerading as Eddie Brock the best
that Eddie could do was send his mind
into the past and try to warn Dylan but
it was all part of the plan of Meridius
who figured that Eddie would do that and
that led to quote unquote Eddie Brock
appearing to die and then Dylan being
bonded with the Venom symbiote with the
hope that Meridius could track his son
down and then of course absorb the
Symbiote into himself but all of this is
done by Meridius basically manipulating
the timeline to ensure that Eddie Brock
becomes Meridius whereas Eddie Brock is
trying to prevent that from happening
and so what's cool here is he tells Dr
Doom I need to physically send my body
into the past because I need to go to
that moment when my future evil self
right Meridius contacts Dylan and
pretends to be me and I can bust in the
door and I can say Dylan that's not me
that's an evil future version of myself
I can't do that if all I can do is send
my mind into the past because every time
I do the situation and scenario plays
out the exact same what I need from you
Doctor Doom is your time platform now
one of the things to know here is one of
the coolest things about Doctor Doom
right this guy can legitimately time
travel and in Marvel Comics it can be
done in different ways it can be done in
the same way that Dr Doom does when he
basically Blends magic and science to
create the time platform people like
Doctor Strange can do it using spells
people like Silver Surfer used to be
able to do it back during the old Jim
Starling days just by using the power
Cosmic right you can use the time Stone
you can do it in any number of different
forms but Dr Doom's time platform is a
highly coveted device that's sought
after by so many people and he keeps
this thing under lock and key even Reid
Richards of the Fantastic Four is smart
enough not to try to break into Dr
Doom's castle and steal his time
platform Thanos wouldn't even try to do
it right like attempting that is
absolute Folly if there's anything
Doctor Doom will fight you to the death
over it's exactly that and a perfect
example of this is when he says out of
the question Liberia does not have a
policy of allowing Firearms Within Reach
of children neither do I allow
potentially Universe destroying
Technologies into the hands of and I say
this with all the respect that one king
owes another of violent Maniac somebody
who got a hold of Dr Doom's time
platform could travel back all the way
to the very beginnings of life on Earth
prevent the first you know multi-celled
organism from coming into existence and
that's the end of all all life on the
planet right I mean you could literally
destroy the entirety of the world the
entirety of the universe by manipulating
time so it's one of those things where
he keeps it under lock and key and he
even tells Eddie Brock return home
return to your son he surely needs you
more than whatever Quest you're on that
yes you could go back and you could
basically prevent your son from ever
becoming Venom in the first place and
Meridius manipulating things and so on
and so forth or you could go find your
son and be a father and you could teach
him how to Be an Effective superhero now
that he's already on this path but
that's the thing Doctor Doom doesn't
really see the bigger picture he doesn't
see that it's not just about stopping
Meridius from effectively engineering a
set of circumstances that would lead to
Eddie's son becoming Venom it's also
Eddie trying to stop himself from
becoming this Uber evil version of
himself in the future and so once they
both realize that they're at an impasse
the response of Doctor Doom is okay so
should we finish my meal or do you just
want to get things started and of course
Eddie manifest the Bedlam Samir and then
immediately goes after Doctor Doom now
the cool thing here is fighting Doctor
Doom in his own castle that is a Fool's
errand if there ever was one because the
first thing he does is he uses magic and
just summons a demonic hand From Another
Dimension which immediately sees as
Eddie Brock but given the Boost of
Eddie's power and what he's capable of
he just starts breaking the fingers
of this demon and in turn it just
Retreats back into from Winter King
right it just goes back to its place and
then following that the Fight Continues
between the two but something to
understand here Dr Doom is fighting to
kill that's one of the things that I
want you guys to be aware of here right
he's intending to destroy Eddie Brock
but he can't Eddie's either too fast or
he's too durable and he handsomely be
destroyed through conventional means
literally there's a point where Doctor
Doom blasts him with the this energy
source and it just kind of blows a hole
in him he immediately heals and then
sends Bedlam after Doctor Doom which is
enough to kind of chew on him and bite
him up a little bit but it leads to
Eddie having just enough time to be able
to locate the time platform and that's
when Doom is like okay look this was fun
in games before now you're irritating me
now you're frustrating me if you do not
back away from that time platform I will
eradicate you in your entirety and
presumably given all the level of magic
and all the power the Doctor Doom has he
genuinely believes that he can but the
reality is he cannot he cannot destroy
any Rock and he simply just doesn't know
it and so while Eddie Brock is nowhere
near intelligent enough to be able to
decipher how to activate this time
platform just given the complexity of
what it takes to get this thing up and
running he does exactly the next best
thing exactly what you would expect
Eddie Brock to do when in fear when in
doubt hit it with a hammer and he just
starts smashing this thing
he just starts smashing the control box
for the time platform and then what do
you know the thing activates the
question that has to be asked here is
where are these guys being teleported to
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end if you want to get
caught up on Venom make sure you guys
click this link to the playlist and I
will catch you all later peace